we all want to have a good time this
summer I personally look forward to the
summertime every single year because I
live in British Columbia and 90 of the
year is overcast rainy gloomy cloudy
it's not a fun time when the weather
starts to get good I really start to
think every single year how am I going
to make this summer count how am I going
to feel good take advantage of the nice
weather what things can I do to sort of
make some memories if you're anything
like me you don't want to have a
summertime where you're just inside all
the time rotting away feeling depressed
because everybody that you know on
Instagram or people that you don't know
on Instagram are traveling to Greece
they're in the Bahamas having a great
time and you just feel like about
yourself how do we avoid that situation
how do you have an adventurous
fulfilling exciting summer well as a
summer Enthusiast myself over the past
27 years of my existence I've been
asking myself that same question and
I've developed some answers so I want to
share those answers with you guys here
are five things that I randomly just
thought of I made it the up but
have taken me 27 years to realize that
will hopefully help you have the best
summer that you've had in years
potentially the best summer that you've
ever had in your entire life tip number
one and this is very simple but it's
extremely important wake up earlier
unless you're working a shift job where
you have to wake up super early anyways
the summer time is the best time to wake
up about an hour earlier than you
usually do that involves also going to
bed an hour earlier as well go figure
when you lay in bed and you don't do
anything with your life and you rot away
inside it feels extra bad because you
just have this idea that the whole world
is going on without you and that's why I
think it's so important to wake up early
during the summer time don't let the sun
catch you sleeping I personally find
that the summertime mornings have a
magical aura about them there's
something very special about you know
the bugs flying around and the birds
chirping and the the sunrise coming up
you know the world is waking up and if
you wake up with that there's something
so ancient and special about that you're
part of the rhythm of the universe as
woo-woo as that sound so give it a try
wake up earlier this summer you can't go
wrong and right along the same lines tip
number two is to go outside as much as
humanly possible unless you have a very
good reason to be inside go outside it's
summer what are you doing
summer if you're just Doom scrolling on
your phone inside just go to a coffee
shop sip a nice ice coffee and people
watch instead while Doom scrolling on
your phone I guarantee you being a
person in the world doing nothing will
feel infinitely better than being a
recluse doing nothing because just being
around people being outside of your
house subjecting yourself to social
judgment it'll make you second guess
your choices in life isolation is
degenerative in large quantities I had
this thought recently so many people are
so addicted to their phones and their
computers their laptops Netflix just
basically screens and they hide away
inside regardless of the weather which
means that if you are of the awoken
variety and you understand the healing
nature of the Sun and you decide to go
against the tyrannical screen culture
the likelihood that you meet people on
the exact same wavelength as you is so
much higher because the people who are
doom scrolling our Doom scrolling inside
which means yeah there's just such high
quality optimistic people when you leave
your house nowadays you'd be shocked as
to how many like random Beautiful People
you come across when you're just on a
walk and you choose to make eye contact
and you say hey what's up personal
challenge go try to chat up a stranger
you'd be shocked as to how receptive
people are and how friendly people are
okay tip number three is to optimize
your environment are you going to design
your environment in a way that keeps you
stuck inside and not want to leave or
are you going to design your environment
you know your home your bedroom your
kitchen wherever you reside in a way
that refreshes you and recharges you to
go back out into the world and continue
the momentum continue the adventure of
your life recently I've been very
cognizant of this you know I don't want
to make my house too comfortable I don't
want to rig out my gaming PC I don't
want to get a comfier and comfier couch
with a bigger and bigger screen I want
to make sure that my clothes are clean
my laundry is done quality of life
things that help you feel good so that
you can go back out there it's like the
ultimate pit stop in NASCAR I don't
watch Nascar like is it called pit stop
I don't know who watches NASCAR
there's cars that go fast and I know
they they like pull away and there's
like the guys that have the the drills
or something and they put the wheels on
really fast the tires on really fast I
don't know make your house like that or
something I don't give a tip number
four is don't try to recreate the Golden
Years be present instead what I mean by
this is that if you're a summer
Enthusiast like me you probably have
memories of days gone by that perfect
summer that you had that perfect moment
when you were camping with your friends
when you were 17 years old you were
lying on the beach and everything just
felt right those were the good times
those were the days man I wish I could
go back in time
I take State you know what maybe you're
really inspired to make this summer like
the good old days right you know you you
try to reflect on what made those days
so good and you try to just like do that
again
do it again trying to recreate the
golden years doesn't work
you can't compare the present moment
with this like propagandized version of
your past memories are a completely
different ball game like doing with my
life the present life will just never
feel like your memories but one thing
that you can do to ensure that you
create new good favorable memories is to
just focus on being present do the exact
opposite of reminiscing about the good
old days try to be present with your own
reality don't distract yourself with
dopaminergic rabbit holes you know
that's the opposite of being present
instead think about the people in your
life who you want to spend time with the
things that you want to do and set up a
schedule to spend time with these people
you know phone them up what do you
personally want to accomplish with your
summer and then focus on that be present
with that when you fully engage in your
activities when you're really
intentional about how you spend your
time you'll find that memories are
created automatically
favorite some memories of all time is
when myself and my siblings were back in
our hometown and we made an effort to
jump in the lake every single day no
matter what no matter how we're feeling
no matter whether it's raining whether
it's like blistering heat whether it's
midnight or midday let's just jump in
the lake every single day this summer
it's almost like baptizing yourself in
the waters of summertime it's a very
optimistic thing to do make Adventure a
mechanism take emotion out of it do
things that are good for you
automatically without considering how
you feel
shot a cow with a bazooka I'm not proud
of that last one but I did it man so
often we'll talk ourselves out of going
to the gym when we don't feel like it
but sometimes you know we don't feel
like going to the gym but we go to the
gym anyways and then afterwards we feel
so good and so empowered that we went
anyways despite the fact that we didn't
feel like it so clearly how we feel
after having done the thing is a better
indicator of the value that thing has in
our lives than before having done the
thing
man I'm bad at grammar today did that
make any sense hey
no bottom line is you already know
what's good for you usually these things
are moderately to majorly uncomfortable
but you have to do these things anyways
as a mechanism like clockwork and also
if you live near a body of water I
highly recommend that specific challenge
I guarantee you I'm letting you in on a
little secret here the mental benefits
of that specific challenge are insane by
the way I think we only did it like 36
days in a row like we didn't last the
whole summer but those 36 days are so
immortalized in our summer archives our
summer memories that my brother gifted
me this go jump in the lake plaque as a
reminder just to do things like this
automatically whether or not you feel
like it because they'll turn into some
of the best memories of your life okay
my final tip
is to be okay don't succumb to fomo
nobody's having nearly as good of a time
as you think they are mental health is
at a critical moment right now don't add
to that by looking on Instagram and
thinking that everybody has it all
figured out and you don't no one has it
figured out 99 of people don't have it
figured out realize that
get off Instagram don't just don't be on
it in general especially during the
summer time don't be Doom scrolling take
a deep breath
and realize that you're okay you don't
have to do any like crazy Outer Banks in
order to have a good summer in the
morning when you're waking up nice and
early
do what's good for you do what advances
your life and your goals work hard in
the morning so that you can have nice
patio conversations during the evening
but ultimately just be present with all
these things don't distract yourself
with the bulk of screens and Netflix or
Apple TV silos not that good first three
episodes were quite good and it's
starting to drag
good luck guys you're gonna need it so I
injured my shoulder playing hockey
recently and it's been keeping me out of
the gym luckily today's video sponsor
co-pilot has helped me out a ton not
only are all of the workouts on co-pilot
extremely easy to follow they're
tailored specifically to you and not by
some auto-generated algorithm but by an
actual personal trainer because when you
join co-pilot you start with an
onboarding call with your coach and
after talking for a while they will
create a custom workout plan tailored to
your specific needs during my own
onboarding call Coach Nate and I were
able to discuss my shoulder injury try
to figure out where it was at and he
gave me a series of shoulder stabilizing
and strengthening exercises that I could
do that have really been invaluable to
gaining strength back in my weak
appendage and has expediently put me on
the path to lifting heavy again when I
was previously completely out of the gym
and even while I'm doing these new
stabilizing exercises that I previously
wouldn't have done the app will correct
me in real time if my form is off to
make sure that I'm doing them optimally
and that I don't get injured again
simply put co-pilot put me back in the
gym and I'm not alone because over 75
percent of users are still working out
after a hundred days which is nine times
more successful than average so if you
want to join me on a fitness journey of
your own that you'll actually stick to
then click my link in the description
below or scan the code to get 14 days
free with your own health and fitness
coach once again take advantage of that
link or scan the code thanks again to
co-pilot for sponsoring this video I was
feeling super good today I did a lot of
work outside on a Starbucks patio
sipping a chai tea latte I don't know
why I I chose a hot chai tea latte and
it was just killer heat today not a wise
decision thank you so much and we'll
catch you in the next video
hey
so what do you think